back in the day we used to fear more
sickness ah starvation it was a guys
it's tears getting eaten by porcupines
today there's a different kind of threat
shitty tweets that will get you fired
there's the girl that dressed up as a
victim in the Boston Marathon shooting
sorry seriously seriously okay she may
she may be deserted
we have the Taco Bell employee that peed
in a Taco Bell why did he get fired life
is not fair we're all a tweet away from
losing our job we have justine sacco who
tweeted going to africa hope I don't get
AIDS just kidding um white jesus [ __ ]
christ
maybe my tweets are not that bad but I'm
gonna read the tweets that I never
pressed tweet on their saved here in my
tweet drafts they're not gonna be
anywhere near as bad they're just gonna
be either unfunny shitty I'm gonna
regret doing this okay all kids should
be sent to islands and fight like Hunger
Games but instead they just watch
YouTube and make my job possible thanks
I still stand by that I still stand by
all kids should be sent to fight like
the hunger games that we entertainment
we'd had less annoying kids on airplanes
there's never enough days that it's my
birthday
no there isn't can there can it be my
birthday today please everyone type in
the shed happy birthday PewDiePie
Voltron
sorry is this as a European this whole
election thing as an outsider
perspective is just funny and that's why
it's funny to joke about but I realized
if I ever tweeted that [ __ ] and someone
would retweet it it would look bad it
would look bad next one is a picture I
[Music]
forgot about this one this might be one
of my favorite tweets ever I've saved
this one for so long so this girl named
Avery tweeted met PewDiePie at Victory
Grill the other day great guy well I'm
sure he's a great guy but that that
ain't me Avery promise me you won't tell
Avery about this person because I still
want her to think that I'm a nice guy
moving on woke up from my stomach
growling
so I had a snack and stop the problem
but it turns out it was my dog's stomach
so I ate the dog but this is like all my
shitty jokes pretty much which is my
Twitter feed anyway so I didn't see why
editing just click send on that I guess
tweeting about eating your dog didn't
really seem appropriate but if you knew
my dog it would totally be broccoli
that's hilarious
that's hysterical everyone a round of
applause in matter of fact I'm gonna
tweet it right now I'm not gonna hold
back any more broccoli
how do you spell it broccoli boom this
[ __ ] better get tight open a window
either Edgar or the earth farted because
something smells dead yeah that must
have been the earth that farted
hilarious hilarious comedy thank you
very much I'm here all night except
right now I have this videos to [ __ ] so
I'm just gonna go thank you though
appreciate it
you smart that Liz leaves known even no
one I remember this gaming on PC instead
of console is like a toaster versus
keeping the bread between your ass
cheeks I think I think I put X box
instead of PC instead of Xbox but I
didn't want to I don't want to upset
anyone over an Xbox cuz they might still
give me free [ __ ] you know I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna burn that bridge as much
as a piece of [ __ ] you are Xbox you can
give me free [ __ ] so I'm not gonna ruin
that wait I missed 2014 when views would
just keep coming despite [ __ ] cut it's
true I remember back in 2014 that's when
my channel got big and I barely put any
effort into my videos back then I'm not
gonna lie they were pretty [ __ ] not all
of them but a lot of them and I I would
get so many of you I will get so many of
you why does that not happen with too
many other youtubers now y'all watchin
leafy and rice them is that why am I not
good enough I see how it is I'm a
passing trend huh I'm not interesting
enough a1 sorry sorry I don't talk close
to the money
I'm the worst channel on YouTube see the
reason why I didn't tweet this is
because I know everyone is gonna just be
like yeah we know I know you guys I know
you guys on Twitter you try and be so
[ __ ] clever and smirky I'm gonna I'm
gonna prove it to you all right
boom all right let's see the responses
all right tweet has been up for 20
seconds let's see here
agreed true true
yep yes yes you're right true yeah lawl
indeed not the worst same true sucks men
y'all think you're so clever huh
planning to start a Team Rocket with
Edgar and go out and steal people's
iPhones that's a great idea dude I just
need that apparel this is I'm gonna do
this all right this is my applying see
after YouTube oh my god there's one for
dogs the Ghostbusters movie wasn't
actually that bad then the reason I
didn't tweet this was because everyone
hates the movie on the internet doesn't
matter it doesn't matter everyone hates
the movie I thought it'd be funny if I
say that it wasn't actually bad but I
meant it ironically because I hated it
my hair stop commenting about it listen
if I want a fringe you can [ __ ] let
me have a French right here's another
one sorry losers and haters but my IQ is
one of the highest and you all know it
please don't feel so stupid or insecure
it's not your fault oh [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] that was Donald Trump sorry sorry
mr. Trump I didn't mean to plagiarize
your tweet my bad future president of
America everyone all right let's see
what tweets I've actually deleted and I
can talk about why I deleted them all
right this is how I treated to Matthew
Santoro
why didn't I tweet this to matthew sent
i can't believe some of you still ask
what my snapchat is isn't it obvious now
I used beautify for everything and I
tweeted we all have our tricks to see 12
year old kids ah this is a big deal this
tweet this tweet got me in a lot of
trouble
actually on tumblr people are very upset
that I tweeted this stupid joke stupid
joke about pedophilia two years ago
can't do that you can't do that I've
learned my lesson I'm sorry no the joke
was that I I know for a fact that
youtubers use their snapchat to get tits
from under underage fans all right not
mentioning any names now mentioning any
names but I know it's been done alright
I thought I never that's why I never
even got a snapchat because I think it's
so [ __ ] up so I made a joke about it
I'm sorry you know what I'm sorry it's
not like I did it I'm innocent
why do I get the [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ]
get the tits glad we got that out yeah
glad we cleared the air Jesus this is a
terrible idea
I'm going to take my Korean k-pop hair
and I'm gonna go go that was a disss
been absolutely great I'll never do this
again
listen look there's my haircut there it
is again why did I do this I'm just
gonna go thank you so much for watching
this video I would like if you enjoyed
watching and as always stay awesome Russ
scares has come out as homosexual we
reached out to scarce or a comment about
the situation and I'm gay I told my
parents I'm gay all right and my mom is
super homophobic um both like your mom
and my dad actually like grab my balls
and they both sincerely think I'm gay
now oh my god I just I can't [ __ ]
believe it and I'll see other piece I'm
gay
[Music]